all right so this question comes in two
pieces
find the derivative first and then
secondly find when the derivative is a
certain value okay so let's have a look
at this and this is a challenging one
first principles is a long process and
so we try we often give you fairly
simple functions up here this is a bit
of a mess because of that denominator
okay so let's have a go at this I do
want to point out actually are they here
no I think I took him to worry first
principles on the reference sheet so you
can you can take advantage of that
however first principles is not that
hard to remember if you remember what
what the derivative is the derivative is
about finding the gradient of a function
right so let's do this together I'm
gonna make this little subheading first
principles by definition gradient is
rise over run yeah so if I think about
rise over run first principles just say
says pick an ax for excel you can go a
little bit further right so the x value
might be f of X and if you go a little
bit further
that'll be f of X plus h where H is my
little bit further okay if I want to
find out rise then I'm just taking the
difference between those okay just like
I would put in y2 minus y1 into my
gradient formula that's the rise but
then the run is just that little bit
further do you remember that so that's
why it's just H now this is almost first
principles it's missing something this
is gradient between two points y2 minus
y1 there they are and this is what you
would get from x2 months x1 but I don't
actually want the gradient between two
points that would just give me a secant
first principals gives me something
better than that it gives me the
gradient of a tangent so what I have to
add this
they´ll limit very good so never been
assessed on this before so that's why
this is a big deal now they provide for
you this particular f of X so the first
thing you do is just do the substitution
okay there's my limit and for those of
you who were asking before yes you must
write it every time
because if I didn't have a limit there
will be a different gradient okay what
is f of X plus h in this case have a
look I'll give you a clue it starts with
a 1 over so everywhere I saw X in the
original function I'll just substitute
in X plus h which is the nurse says is X
plus h minus 1 that's that function and
then over here I'm going to have 1 over
X minus 1 that's f of X by definition or
divided through by H okay now remember
where you're going to go from here okay
what you're expecting is for something
up here to have an H in it which you can
then cancel out I can't put in H equals
zero right now because H is on the
denominator okay so you have a pair of
fractions up there what's the likely
thing that you might do okay if I
multiply everything by X plus h minus 1
that would get rid of this and it will
put X plus h minus 1 down here that's
good but I also have this to get rid of
right I've got an X minus 1 so I should
probably multiply by that also does that
make sense so here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna multiply the top and the
bottom by both these denominators okay
and that'll get rid of all the fractions
on the top and it'll put some extra
factors on the bottom because I multiply
top and bottom okay so I'm gonna do the
bottom first which is a bit
counterintuitive I've got X plus h minus
1 X minus 1 like so and then on the top
when you multiply this fraction by this
what do you get you'll just get this
right cuz the X plus h minus ones
they'll cancel with each other so we'll
just get this guy and then when I do the
same to the second fraction what will
happen yeah I'll just get this because
the X minus one's just like before
they'll cancel by the way I'm putting
everything in brackets anyone wanna
suggest why I'm doing that why is that a
good idea
so that when I expand things because you
notice this minus sign here which is
kind of gonna trip me up when I expand
things I'm going
get all the signs correct okay now
before I go any further this looks weird
and random they've given you a bit of a
hand by actually telling you what answer
you ought to expect now I just want you
to have a look at actually really you're
gonna have to tell me again what they're
requiring us to prove I think it's what
is it minus 1 over X minus 1 whole
squared yep
I'm just doing it in my head so when you
have a look at that see how there's an X
minus 1 all squared on the bottom that's
what I'm expecting to get just have a
look at this denominator down here have
a look do you see that I should get
there I should because eventually H is
going to become 0 which means this will
be X minus 1 this will also be X minus 1
so I'm on the right track okay
I'm not quite there yet though have a
look at the numerator there's going to
be some serious cancelling that happens
at the top right let's get another color
here to help us what's going to happen
to the X terms
they're all gone X is it gone what about
that negative 1 also gone because
negative 1 take away negative 1 is 0 so
all you get left with on the top is yeah
just watch out that sign minus H all
over blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
and this is what I was hoping for right
this is exactly what I was hoping for on
the numerator I've just got a single H
and that's going to cancel cancel so my
final line will be a final line pretty
much will be I can now evaluate the
limit I can actually try out and see
what happens when H gets to 0 you're
going to have a negative 1 on the top
you're going to have X plus 0 minus 1
and X minus 1 like so I'm pretty much
there I know this last line doesn't get
any marks because it was provided to you
so in fact once you get to this line you
get the two ticks or yeah it'll be two
ticks or something like this ok does
that make sense
see what I did so just to finish out
part 2 says crimp him along find the
values of X when this is the case find
the values of X okay so this is f dash X
so I'm solving
this equation yep
so someone want to help me out what
could I do to simplify Versailles I
could cross multiply that would work
you're going to get negative 4 over here
and you're going to get negative X minus
1 all squared over there so do the
negative effect things when I cross
multiply in this case in this case they
look okay in fact the reason why is
because what I'm multiplying by is just
these guys down the bottom which are
both positive do you notice that but
even so this is an equation you can
multiply by negative numbers that's okay
what is it that I multiply by negative
numbers and it does get changed it's not
equations but inequalities and I'm okay
I'm in the clear from here yeah well
this is the next suggestion I was going
to make because you've got the same
thing on the numerators and you're just
comparing what you want is the
denominators to be the same well those
are the denominators right I suppose
what I'm doing is I'm taking negative
reciprocals of both sides but that's the
same effect I can say X minus 1 equals 2
so I've taken square root of both sides
which means plus or minus 2 and then
this is going to give me two solutions
isn't it if one of these is negative 2
and one is positive 2 when you add 1 to
both of them you should get negative 1
or 3 and you're home ok of course you
can go ahead and you can test that out
but it's not too dramatic you will get
the derivatives the gradients that you
did ok any questions